Well, it happened again...
...another tragedy.
Will we ever learn?
On a day like today,
it's pointless to even post
on social media.
But I absolutely must.
I can't, and I won't,
and I cannot,
and I will not stay silent.
As an American...
As an amateur stand-up
comedian...
As a privileged person
who recognizes
my own privilege...
...it is my duty
to speak out.
Admit it,
you're all just posting
on social media
for the attention.
Today is not about me.
Share my post if you agree.
[Sobbing]
♪♪
Today has
deeply affected me
on a personal level.
My thoughts and prayers
are with the victims
of this horrendous tragedy.
We have to fight fire
with peace fire.
Share my post if you agree.
Just watch.
Tomorrow, you'll go back
to posting selfies
and forget this tragedy
ever happened.
♪♪
[Both sigh]
Feels good
to say something.
It really does.